I went through a westmoreland spiral and
then got to Aaron Aaron Lewis flipping
out my wes borland have you seen that
Aaron Lewis is the head lead singer of
stained stained right who I dig I dig
her and Lewis but there's a I hope Aaron
Lewis doesn't listen to this podcast
because there's a part of Aaron Lewis
that's a little bit maybe not as
sensitive as the artist I'm looking for
so that make sense
hmm there's a part of him where you're
like I think you might have bought into
the branding of you as an artist too
much and you maybe forgot a little bit
who you are it's that fair to say sure
I'm gonna tell you the story of what so
let's just hang on this is so apparent
let me just tell you the backlog of the
story so Aaron Lewis lead singer stained
Boston guy I guess limp Biskit found
stained and brought them on board put
him on the toward them everyone found
staying through them and he runs into
West Moreland in the Jacksonville
Airport and I think Aaron Lewis maybe
it's a little too close to his branding
because this this this monologue he
delivers at a concert live where you can
see that he's rebranding himself a
little bit to be like you know a little
kid rock a little acoustic a little a
little bit like like Everlast
he goes on this tirade I'd I hope he's a
little drunk a little buzzed but this is
what he says about Wes Borland
okay hold on this is where he calls
Westbourne and bougie but I've done this
plenty of times when I'm late for a
light sometimes they'll do this for you
but this is the boo genus that offended
Aaron Lewis in the beginning to his fans
he's telling us to his fans is the first
time in my life where I want to stop
using the term brother I use it non-stop
it's kind of my way of talking to people
I do feel a Brotherhood within guys
sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like their the Cable Guy
branding of like I'm somewhere clearly
that's he maybe he's in Jacksonville I
guess I'm assuming and it's just easy to
[ __ ] on a lane of them and there's like
oh you're not from there but hey man
like I nothing but respect to Earth
Lewis but I don't say like when they're
there like we're flying it and I go I'm
finding my kids house hey man you're
from Tampa have a pool follow where my
parents bought a new house I've never
lived it about to pass out oh oh I mean
like it's just so ridiculous they like
yeah this is my home
Oh Oh and [ __ ] Aaron Lewis got so
upset okay do so then so then
immediately this is what I do in
comedies I flip it right I don't agree
with there and losing this but
immediately if you're a comic you flip
it you go all right let's take a look at
the other side so then I'm like alright
I'm Aaron Lewis by the way I've done
this a lot I've done this a lot right
been drunk in an airport air clearly
eran Luce's drunk in an airport no one
has a conversation with someone sober
and goes hey [ __ ]
that's not your home who tells him to
grown man drunk on stage right there -
oh he's drunk on stage too
you're a real person you're not the
plastic dump people that live in Los
Angeles come on Aaron in saying that
you're being a little plastic you're
playing to your Aaron Aaron stop say it
again
who is this guy
reminding my brother never walk the face
of the earth
what's gonna call Geechee next Yugi Chi
[ __ ] I don't even know get you I
think eat you you ever live in South
Carolina he's about to play you can keep
up with that there by the way rock feed
is the name of the podcast I sold it on
I don't dislike Aaron Lewis I actually
like him more now I like a guy that
that's me that's me who [ __ ] waxes
poetically about some [ __ ] that I did
drunk and then I'm the victim in it but
I've made me [ __ ] love Westbourne I'm
sure Westmoreland I'm sure he's a
[ __ ] nightmare to be around I'm
certain of it I think both of them might
be a little bit of a but in this story I
side with Wes of like hey man where you
going home Oh mother listen brother hey
I'm just going home man I think he
didn't like [ __ ]
[Music]